I'm gonna fly the drone off the balcony
that's what I'm gonna do not do you
won't experience the drone yeah alright
she's set up she's ready all we're gonna
do is just one quick zip out there and
back well that is super concerned I'm a
very cautious person that's the only
reason why
[Applause]
[Music]
the problem was I was trying to get a
really cool shot of us so I was gonna
bring it in front of us and then get
picture before I landed but I uh we've
got a problem
the good thing is these things are all
pretty inexpensive to replace in
relation to an entire drill let's go
let's go please I had to go on a little
trail and take Maddy it's like a 1.5
mile loop so I thought it'd be easy
enough for him
but while we were crossing the street he
ran across this room booked it and then
took a crap right in the middle of a
street well we tried to cross the street
and then he he
Maddy decided that you people had to do
oh god there's a motorcycle the
emergency override
come on oh gosh come on Maddy trying to
walk the dog and we could never go okay
what's wrong
really V&H off him hello so let's knock
off - - he's like that's nature it's
nadeshot nature we just hiked all up
there now we're gonna go on the pedal
path he was a good boy he wants down
though so bad we gotta cross the street
yeah cuz you you pooped while we were
crossing Street last time but it's
really really
what adventure should we do next is the
question oh gosh oh boy oh boy how about
you Oh some puppies coming up Matt he's
gonna lose his mind he's gonna lose it
we think it's a Maltipoo we got him in
the shelter so we're not sure like a
multi spoodle are you having fun in the
backseat look at you
smelling Maddy from earlier today now
it's your turn to get out he's trying to
get out and party home Mattie earlier he
was such a good boy uh I just from the
sunset hmm not a good sunset sue me sue
me sue me and everywhere look at you
just marking up a storm you showing
everybody what's up we just got back
from Big Bear Jenna's over there
watching the dogs because I'm gonna play
some halo
he's so wild this is not really good
unboxing it's just uh hey I need to open
this now
Oh get some paper
oh my gosh I'm gonna super cute okay it
is really really pretty
I hope they decide to make it in white
here's all the pieces basically I'm just
gonna play with it and it's just like
magnets like - mmm looks good I think
right I'm gonna put this I'm assuming
this is probably oh my goodness if I
want to plug you in I can so I'm
probably gonna switch these
to be up here I think I thought well
we're gonna try it and see what happens
with halo all right these batteries in
the batteries there's somebody want to
come play Halo with me look at him Oh
excuse me mommy wants to play Halo it's
focusing so this is the end of this
video I'm not even sure what it was in
this video so I apologize but I'll see
you guys in the Internet I'm excited for
video games season new video game season
it's out it's time
halo now call duty next week things are
getting wild okay wait it's still
updating I want to play the freaking
game let me play the game we did a
little calculating of the time a little
wrong it's completely pitch black oh my
gosh